[Music]
you look absolutely stunning
I love your dress - shouldn't do that
but yeah you look amazing we both got
black on that's the other we're not
alike in any way that's me paying you a
compliment
you look fantastic and obviously for
anyone who doesn't know you're from
England you have an English accent
you're from where in England I'm from
Facebook bombing Ham Birmingham England
I've heard of Birmingham who's the most
famous person from Birmingham I think
the most famous person would probably be
Ozzy Osbourne yes that's him yeah yeah
it's funny because Aussie Osbourne for
all the crazy things he does life he has
such a beautiful accent I really like
your accent it's a very distinguished
act distinguished accent yes yeah he the
burning maxim is very particular it's
quite strong as you know from Ozzy
Osbourne right but we have there's all
these like strange phrases I don't know
if you I don't know them now that's like
a time if you're if you really like
someone then you call them your mucker
your your mucker yeah yeah sounds like
that doesn't sound a bit of I saw you
and obviously I like you but if I saw
you what I said like oh you're my mucker
that doesn't sound very nice it doesn't
sound yes it does yeah but that's that's
the kind of Birmingham way yeah okay
okay this muck or implied that there's a
relationship going on or just that we're
pals that you're pals and you really
like that person okay you'd say you're
my like good marker okay that's just
that's that's terrible
then again you do that with your food
all the time your food can be actually
be really can be very good but you'll
have names for it like have some chutney
and flop flop you know what it doesn't
sound it doesn't sound that tape it
doesn't sound that well the chutney is
very good I want to ask you you you're
from England now you're here at living
in Los Angeles how big a change is that
for you must be a huge adjustment
yeah well coming for an English person
coming to Los Angeles it's it's like
coming to heaven because everyone's
really nice to you
people smile at you people make
conversation with
unlike I live in London so it's the
complete opposite nice yeah mostly you
ignore and you know people try and run
you over and that kind of thing
where I try to run you over do your
walking to the cheese no mutters try and
take you down yeah Wow okay so you
really like it here and you're you think
you've grown accustomed are you uh I'm
getting used to it I am the one thing
I'm finding is proving challenging is
the driving another correct side of the
street here right I hope so yeah I think
most of the time I am but it's just it's
just I thought I was here um I think I
got in one week they just crazy in this
minute if I could I'd turn my back yeah
three parking tickets and I revived
three parking tickets
okay crashed my car and you crashed your
car I mean you weren't hurt or anything
you're out you know I was okay I
survived how did you how did you yes you
did survive how did you how did you
crash your car I revert I was in like
like trying to get out of a parking
structure and I managed to just like hit
the post as I was coming out right and
the whole thing just like there was a
big dent and we said the whole thing I
he said the whole parking structure came
down the whole thing collapsed other
people were terribly hurt but I'm fine